they create worlds from thin
air they tell stories in silence
i'm talking of course about mimes and
the man considered the most famous
mime in history was not only a
world-renowned performer
but also saved children from the nazis
during world war
ii
[Music]
that man was marcel marceau mercenar so
is probably
the most iconic image of mime
and that's sean wen hi she's the author
of a 20-minute silence followed by
applause
a book about marceau's life the way that
we picture mime is someone who
performs without speaking and a lot of
this
has to do with marcel marceau he really
influenced a lot of our visual culture
michael jackson's moonwalk is modeled
after his walking against the wind
he performed up until his death in 2007
and he toured the world over and over
again
[Music]
before his legacy as a mime marceau was
a young boy in france
it was here he would find his hero in
the movies
his inspiration was charlie chaplin his
humor
his use of physicality even from a young
age marceau
displayed this kind of like uncanny
physical gift
however in may of 1940 marceau's life
would change forever
marceau was 16 years old when germany
marched on france
and his childhood ended all at once
marco's father died in auschwitz and
both
he and his brother were very much
involved in the war effort against the
nazis
and it was marceau's skills as a
performer that made him a unique asset
there's a story about marcel marceaux
saving a group of children
from an orphanage he dressed them up as
campers and he would walk them
into safety in switzerland he was doing
mimicry and he was acting and
essentially he was entertaining them to
the point where they could pretend as if
they were going on vacation
rather than you know fleeing for their
lives
[Music]
another story was that he was
encountering
a large group of 30 german soldiers
and in that moment he pretended that he
was actually at the front
of a large group of french soldiers
and they actually surrendered to him it
seems as if
this natural knack for acting
ended up becoming a part of his
involvement in the war effort
it's been described that he wasn't just
miming because he loved mime
during the war he was miming for his
life
in many ways marceau's wartime
experience would shape his life's work
he spent his life circling the world
over and over again
telling these stories through his body
in a way that defied language
there's something about that that almost
seems like
an effort to bring the world back
together doing something that anyone
regardless of
language or nationality can understand
just by looking at him
you